the Serbian flag being taken down please
replace it with the Kosovo flag outside
the building that's all clashes between
serbs and Kosovo authorities
the streets bear the signs of the battle
of the previous day but there's still a
strong police presence Germany is the
latest country critical of kosovo's
response towards its Serb minority I'm
very convinced that yesterday was a bad
day
for Kosovo and for the whole Western
Balkans region locals have also voiced
their objections to the police response
[Music]
we try to speak to the police and their
Commander peacefully to reduce tensions
to find some other solution but they
would not listen to us they started to
use Force they threw tear gas at us
shock bombs
Kosovo authorities say they were trying
to fulfill their obligations to the
Constitution serbs here have left key
institutions and boycotted recent
elections they then objected to ethnic
Albanian Mayors taking office who were
elected the streets in Northern Kosovo
are full of Serbian Flags but it's not
just served nationalism that authorities
find problematic a mural to Bosnian Serb
war criminal adich foundability of war
crimes and crimes against humanity but
he's seen as a hero here International
forces monitor a fragile peace and
there's a real fear the situation could
get worse if there isn't a de-escalation
yesterday it was on the edge of a real
conflict the Kosovo government has to
understand that you can't build trust
with citizens serbs in the Norfolk
Kosovo by sending Special Forces unusual
Force the International Community has to
take urgent measures to prevent further
escalations because the consequences
could be devastating communities are
divided along ethnic lines in mitroviche
it's just a bridge everywhere we look
here we see a strong sense of Serbian
nationalism the Kosovo authorities may
have won the battle for the Mayors
entering the municipality buildings but
they still face the considerable
challenge of how they make an ethnic
served population feel a part of a
majority ethnic Albanian Kosovo when
many here don't recognize the Republic
self-declared Independence or recognizes
institutions and would much rather
Kosovo be a part of Serbia
Al Jazeera
sir